مشاهدينا البدايه من حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا اذ اعلن الجيش الاوكراني عن تقدم
في محاور عده لا سيما في الشرق حيث
المعارك تتواصل مع القوات الروسيه خدمه
الطوارئ الاوكرانيه افادت بسقوط عشرات
القتلى والجرحى جراء قصف روسيا صاروخي
استهدف منطقه ريبري شمال مقاطعه خيسون
بينما قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها
تصدت لهجمات بطائرات مسيره استهدفت اكثر
من منطقه لتسليط الضوء اكثر على التفاصيل
المشهد الميداني تحديدا ينضم الينا من
زابوروجيا الياس كرام ومن دوناتس رانيا
الدريدي ونبدا معك الياس كرام بالحديث عن
اخر التطورات الميدانيه لا سيما ما يتعلق
بالتقدم الذي تتحدث عنه القوات الاوكرانيه
في
زابولوجيا وفي الشرق
نعم لكن اولا بالنسبه لحصيله القصف في
كليفري ارتفعت الحصيله الى 60 جريحا من
بين المدنيين ومن بينهم على الاقل تسعه
ضباط في الشرطه الاوكرانيه بالاضافه الى
شرطي قتيل هذا بحسب خدمه الطوارئ الحكوميه
التي حدثت المعلومات الوارده من كليفري
التي تعرضت الى قصف صاروخي صباح هذا اليوم
بالاضافه الى جريحين ايضا وقع في منطقه
السومي هذه المقاطعه الشماليه
لاوكرانيا حيث طالها ايضا القصف الصاروخي
هذا عن ذلك القوات البريه الاوكرانيه تقول
بانها حققت تقدما على محور باخت في اقليم
الدومباس تحديدا في المحاور الجنوبيه
لباقمت لكن العمليات في هذه المنطقه ما
زالت على حالها في كر وفر بين القوات
الروسيه والاوكرانيه بمعنى ان ايا من
الطرف لم يحققاني اي تقدم كبير في تلك
المناطق والجبهه لم تنهر بالكامل لصالح
ايد من الطرفين سوى ان القتال والمعارك
الدائره على المحاور المختلفه هناك فيكا
ومارينكا
وكذلك في ضخمه وليمه وغيرها من المحاور ما
زالت على حالها وهي على اشدها كما يقول
الجيش الاوكراني بحيث ان الوضع ما زال
صعبا بحسب التوصيل على محور زبالوجيا
الجيش الاوكراني ايضا يقول بانه يحقق
تقدما على المحاور المختلفه للقتال تحديدا
في المحاور الشرقيه الجنوبيه للدومباس في
اوغلادار واوريجينا هذه المناطق التي يسعى
الجيش الاوكراني لتحقيق اختراق من خلالها
وصولا الى بلده فول نافاخا هذه البلده
الاستراتيجيه الهامه على طريق مريومه لهذه
المدينه التي سيطر عليها الجيش الروسي في
الايام الاولى للحرب وفيما اذا تمكن الجيش
الاوكراني من السيطره على فانه يقطع طريق
الامدادات الى مريوبا من جهه الدومباز
وكذلك يسيطر على خط السكك الحديد المدنيه
والعسكريه التي توفر الامدادات من الدباس
من المناطق الشرقيه الى خرسون والى المحور
الاخر الذي يقول الجيش الاوكراني منذ ايام
بانه حقق فيه اختراقا كبيرا هو محور
ريبوتين هذه المناطق يقول الجيش الاوكراني
بانه نجح في تحريرها وانه يتمركز ويعد
الاستحكامات العسكريه هناك ويسعى للتقدم
نحو توقمار التي يقول بانها سقطت عسكريا
رغم انه لن يصلها بعد والوجه نحو
ميلوتوبول وهي عقده ايضا مواصلات مهمه اذا
ما وصلها الجيش الاوكراني كما يتوقع قبل
حلول الشتاء فانه يتوقع انهيارا كبيرا
للقوات الروسيه في جبهه خرسون تحديدا ربما
الصوره مغيره كليا في المناطق التي تسيطر
عليها القوات المواليه
لروسيا رانيا الدريديت وحديثنا عن وجهه
النظر الاخرى بشان سير العمليات والمعارك
في الجنوب والشرق الاوكرانيه
نعم حسن يعني في واقع الامر نحن نعلم ان
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه خلال اليومين
الماضيين نفت اي تقدم للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه لاسيما في محور زباروجيا اشارت
الى ان القوات المسلحه الروسيه لا تزال
تسيطر على المناطق
الجنوبيه والجنوبيه الغربيه لسمه في منطقه
رابوتنا التي لا تزال المعارك قائمه
للسيطره عليها ولكن لا تقدم للقوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه في هذا المحور وفي هذه
المنطقه على الاقل بحسب ما تم الاعلان عنه
من قبل الجانب الروسي فضلا عن ذلك في
العديد من المناسبات يعني حتى من قبل
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين بما في ذلك
خلال اللقاء الاخيره الذي عقده في منتجع
السوشي مع نظيره التركي كان قد اكد على ان
الجانب الاوكراني فاشله في هجومه المضاد
وفاشله بالتقدم في اي من المحاور على
الارض فيما يتعلق بالتطورات الميدانيه
هناك خسائر فادحه بالارواح اود الاشاره
الى ان المعطيات الرسميه الصادره من قبل
الجانب الروسي خلال الايام القليله
الماضيه تفيد بخسائر فادحه الحديث يدور عن
66 الف عسكري اوكراني قتلوا خلال العمليات
العسكريه يعني خلال الشهر الماضي في اطار
الهجوم المضاد يوميا بحسب ما تعلن عنه
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بما في ذلك اليوم
على سبيل المثال تم الاعلان عن القضاء على
اكثر من 600 عسكري اوكرانيا خلال العمليات
العسكريه التي تم تنفيذها فقط خلال
الساعات ال24 الماضي فيما يتعلق بتطورات
الاوضاع على محور دانيتك في هذا المحور
كانت هناك سلسله من الهجمات الحديث يدور
عن 12 هجمه قام بتنفيذها الجانب الاوكراني
خلال اليوم الماضي ولكن كل هذه الهجمات
لاسيما في منطقتي باخموت وفي دانيسك كلها
تم صدها صدها بحسب وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
خمس هجمات في محور اما فيما يتعلق بتطورات
الاوضاع يعني في محور شمالا في هذا الاطار
اكدت الوزاره على ان القوات المسلحه
الروسيه تحسن وتعزز مواقعها في هذه الجبهه
في هذا المحور بشكل عام المعارك يعني
مستمره هناك محاولات لشن عمليات هجوميه
ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه بحسب الاجانب الروسي
كلها باءت بالفشل شكرا لك
وشكرا للياس كرام كان معنا من